second débat tout de suite débat sur les
mutations de la société française sur
ses forces sur ses plaies aussi en voici
une de plaies la violence dans les
stades de football depuis le retour des
supporteurs après une saison blanche
pour cause de qu'ovide les incidents se
multiplient et le ministre de
l'intérieur tente de remettre de l'ordre
sandra serre car
dès la première journée de championnat
le ton a été donné le 8 août dernier le
milieu de terrain de l'om valentin
rongier est touché à la tête par une
bouteille alors qu'il vient de marquer
face à montpellier moins d'un mois plus
tard c'est un autre marseillais dimitri
payet qui est visée à nice envahissement
de terrain bagarre générale le match est
arrêté le 21 novembre payet de nouveau
visé au total neuf matchs ont été
entachées par le comportement des
supporteurs depuis cet été qualifiée d'
urgence absolue par le président de la
ligue de football professionnel vincent
labrune le dossier a été repris en main
par le gouvernement
la réunion de crise du 23 novembre
dernier entre les instances du football
français et les ministres du sport de la
justice et de l'intérieur avait pour
objectif de présenter un plan de lutte
contre les violences dans les stades
quatre pistes sont à l'étude
l'interdiction des stades leur
sécurisation avec par exemple des
caméras de vidéoprotection la question
de la sécurité privée avec le contrôle à
l'accès des stades et enfin le sujet le
plus important selon gérald darmanin
l'accélération du processus de décision
pour arrêter un match l'accélération des
décideurs du processus de décision de
qui arrêtera match comment on arrête un
match quelles responsabilités pour
arrêter ce match entre évidemment le
rôle essentiel dès mardi nous sommes
tous évidemment extrêmement attentifs et
le rôle également du préfet puisqu'il
est une question d'ordre public qui se
pose lorsqu'on évacuent des stades de 30
minutes 40 et 50 mille soixante mille
personnes pour le président de la ligue
il est urgent de changer les règlements
le calendrier des cours mais beaucoup
vont donner les moyens de réussir c
c'est un fléau c'est une urgence absolue
on a conscience de nos responsabilités
une nouvelle réunion devrait avoir lieu
dans les prochains jours pour annoncer
des propositions concrètes afin
d'améliorer la sécurité dans les stades
peut-on finir avec le hooliganisme en
france c'est le thème de notre débat
tout de suite vous présente mes invités
gaëtane morin bonsoir
chef du service politique et sport au
parisien week end michel savin bonsoir
bienvenue et sénateurs l air de l'isère
président du groupe d'études pratique
sportive et grands événements sportifs
ou au sénat sacha ollier bonsoir dans
théorème de la vienne docteur avec
l'ancienne ministre marie george buffet
rapport parlementaire sur le
supportérisme avec nous
en duplex en visioconférence nicolas
hourcade qui est sociologue expert de
ces questions de supporterisme
professeur agrégé de sciences sociales à
l'école centrale de lyon et laëtitia
kamba qui est resté à mes côtés j'espère
bien évidemment et pourquoi pas ces
violences elles ne sont pas
inhabituelles en france il ya eu des
séquences dramatiques dans le passé avec
des morts on se souvient notamment au
paris saint germain comment vous
analysez quand même ce qui se passe
depuis le début de cette saison je
commence avec vous messieurs le ça est
ce que c'est exceptionnel pour vous
à cette hauteur peut être oui et ça
commence à être exceptionnel mais c'est
quelque chose qui malheureusement s'est
inscrit un peu aussi dans la durée au
niveau de certains des stades alors
peut-être que la situation sanitaire
cette situation qu'on vit depuis de
mettre deux ans fait aussi que le
phénomène est en train de s'amplifier ce
qu'on voit dans les stades on le voit
aussi malheureusement dans nos vies n'a
me quartier alors peut-être pas devant
les feux des projecteurs autant que ça a
été le cas alors dû des matchs de foot
mais malheureusement ce soit les espaces
publics
la police la gendarmerie les pompiers
des élus sont
régulièrement agressés il ya cette
violence qui perdure et qui est en train
de prendre beaucoup de plus en plus de
place donc que ce qu'on retrouve dans le
stade dans le on le vit aussi au
quotidien oui avec effectivement ce
parallèle c'est vrai qu'on a été confiné
ont été empêchés de sortir pendant un
certain temps là les supporters
n'avaient pas le droit d'aller au stade
ça a été pendant toute une saison un peu
l'impression que la la soupape
2 à sauter d'une certaine façon vous
diriez ça on pas que la soupape a sauté
mais évidemment quand il ya pas de
supporters il n'y a pas de désordre
après est-ce que ce qu'on attend d'une
société c'est que on ferme tous les
matches et qu'on joue tous les matchs à
10 heures tellement pas n'ont
certainement pas donc c'est la raison
pour laquelle on doit se donner les
moyens
pendant un an et question ça je disais
supporter 01 12h30 sme et que par
ailleurs pour pour les supporters connan
et collectivement c'est une vraie
douleur que de voir des matchs arrêter
des commissions de discipline qui se
réunissent et des décisions qui n'ont
pas lieu ça que je pense qu'il est on va
en parler il ya trois degrés de d'action
de public nouvelle action publique et
dans la prévention et dans
l'organisation des matchs que comment on
sécurise les stades comment on organise
avec les préfets et la ligue les
référents supporters les clubs qui sont
les organisateurs la compétition premier
degré deuxième degré c'est sur le dirt
et judiciaire ça on a des sanctions qui
ont été plus ou moins d'exemplaires en
tout cas à nice avec un homme qui a pris
un an avec sursis un an de prison avec
sursis en peine principale et cinq ans
d'interdiction de stade en peine
complémentaire
la même façon le supporter lyonnais qui
a lancé la bouteille la bouteille sur
dimitri payet il a pris lui également
six mois de prison avec sursis sans
antécédent judiciaire et une peine
complémentaire aussi maximale 5 ans
d'interdiction de stade le judiciaire
fait son travail il troisième élément
qu'est le disciplinaire l'ariane
délégation de service public ce n'est
pas l'état qui sentent qu'il le fait
directement c'est la ligue de football
professionnel qu'est ce qui est le
concessionnaire et qui pour le coup a
agi avec une commission discipline dont
les décisions aujourd'hui sont
interrogés parce que cette commission
est indépendante et qu'elle a rendu
certaines décisions les matches a
rejoint notamment
qui manifestement match à rejouer et big
lots n'ont pas produit les effets
escomptés en termes de wisair d'ego dans
les premiers incidents graves y aurait
pu avoir une réaction disciplinaires
plus plus dur ça c'est ça était en
escale en effet c'est la spirale bon bah
on va on va évidemment continuer d'en
parler on va voir défiler pendant je
vous pose la question la liste des
incidents qui a eu sur les stades de
foot de liga depuis le début de de la
saison je veux bien que vous proposiez
ça gaitan mort à ce qui est frappant
c'est que beaucoup de clubs sont
concernées serre dans le passé on se
disait bon il ya des on sait qu'il ya
des groupes de supporters plus violent
que d'autres quelques clubs qui sont à
risque mais là ça a été un presque un
peu parlé aussi parce qu'en fait il ya
eu un angle mort pendant le confinement
qui est qu'on a préparé la reprise des
stades d'un point de vue économique d'un
point de vue sportif et peut-être qu'on
n'a pas assez anticipé le problème qui
allait surgir des supporters pour deux
raisons la première c'est que d'abord il
ya eu des interdictions de stade qui ont
été élevés puisque le temps du
confinement a quand même été assez long
et le temps de huit clos aussi et puis
des supporteurs qui étaient interdits de
stade et qui ont pu revenu voilà
exactement et l'autre et l'autre raison
c'est aussi que d'un point de vue
économique la ligue va moins bien que il
ya un an et donc du coup en fait ils ont
moins anticipée aussi le nombre de
stadiers nécessaire le peut-être réduit
le budget sécurité ça il faudrait
vérifier et surtout je pense que dans le
dialogue avec les supporters en fait ils
ont ils ont un peu tardé à reprendre
vraiment le fils et à identifier les
bons ils ont des référents en fait des
références supporters avec lesquels ils
dialoguent pour canaliser les ultras et
peut-être que tout ça a fait que
finalement il y avait une espèce de
cocotte minute et ça a explosé un petit
peu à la reprise en août nicolas
hourcade de qui on parle est ce qu'il ya
un profil type du
du ont fait la différence ya les ultras
d'un côté il ya les hooligans de l'autre
hockey est ce qu'il ya un profil type
pour à dire des hooligans par exemple
déjà par rapport à la situation actuelle
pour répondre aux questions
l'émission oui on est dans une situation
exceptionnelle et c'est important de le
souligner depuis les drames que vous
avez évoqué 2009 2010 où il ya eu deux
morts en 2006 puis en 2010 autour du psg
puis un supporter tout simplement en
2009 à belgrade on n'avait jamais eu
autant d'incidents autour des matches de
football français donc ça c'est vraiment
un constat qui est important qu'on
explique comme plusieurs intervenants
l'ordi en partie par la conjoncture
particulière une excitation très forte
avec le retour de plus dans les stades
qui a donné lieu à la fois du positif
avec beaucoup de ferveur mais aussi avec
du négatif avec des incidents et aussi
comme cela a été souligné un déficit
organisationnel puisqu'on avait perdu
des compétences pendant la crise mais
par rapport à ses incidences qu'il faut
relever ces cas plusieurs types
d'incidents qui sont pas similaires il
ya eu des bagarres entre groupes de
supporters dans les stades à angers
marseille notamment autour des stades
dans les centres villes est ce qu'ils
sont des bagarres relativement classique
mais un niveau plus important que
d'habitude et ça c'est préoccupant mais
il ya aussi eu des phénomènes
individuelles qui sont pas du tout liés
aux ultras les jets de projectiles sur
les joueurs sont partis d'autres
tribunes ou en margé tribune des ultras
et pas par des membres actifs de ces
groupes donc on est face à deux
phénomènes différents d'une part des
groupes ultras qu'on identifie et qui
peuvent causer des débordements à
certains moments et d'autre part un
défouloir pour quelques individus isolés
ce qui est beaucoup plus difficile à
prévoir parce que globalement ils sont
pas connues donc pour finir ça suppose
de levier d'action que comme ça chaoulli
la vie d'une part sur le comportement
des supporters et d'autre part sur
l'organisation des matches et si il faut
des sanctions disciplinaires sur les
clubs il faut fondamentalement des
sanctions individuelles sur les fauteurs
de troubles parce que c'est comme ça
qu'un grand pays comme l'angleterre par
exemple à lutter contre le hooliganisme
en ciblant les fauteurs de troubles et
pas en sanctionnant systématiquement
collectivement les clubs et d'ensemble
est supporter on a les moyens de les
trouver puisqu'il ya de la
vidéosurveillance dans tous les stades
on va on va y revenir évidemment
laetitia ce qui vous a frappé c'est que
plusieurs
animateurs qui sont d'anciens joueurs en
appelle directement au président de la
république oui on avait l'habitude que
de nicolas sarkozy qui était très
interventionniste sur le football déjà
en tant que ministre de l'intérieur il
avait émis des lois et puis ensuite
président il a effet voilà il avait eu
plusieurs comme ça mesures contraignant
pour le foot parce qu'on sait que c'est
un spectateur le football peut-être que
c'est un joueur également ça je ne sais
pas emmanuel macron on a vu qu'elle est
chaussé les crampons quand il fallait le
faire quand il devait faire la belle
photo et c'est vrai que c'est ça a
commencé en septembre jérôme rothen par
exemple sur rmc appelle le chef de
l'état à réagir écoutez moi j'en appelle
à macron dire c'est le président qui
doit prendre ses responsabilités aussi
dire le le football aujourd'hui à une
part très importante dans l'économie de
la france donc je suis désolé et dire
qu'on ne soit pas sa part henri c'est à
lui de régler le problème aujourd'hui on
s'est peut-être un peu facile on se dit
que quand on sait pas quoi faire on en
appelle au chef de l'état mais il y
avait aussi sur le plateau pascal olmeta
ancien joueur qui lui a dit moi je vais
carrément envoyé un sms et le président
m'a répondu donc pour l'instant emmanuel
macron apparemment communicants of sur
le sujet parce que il n'y a pas de prise
de parole ni de tweets je suis allé voir
sur son fil twitter voir s'il avait un
peu twitté réagi parce que c'est quand
même un sujet qui est très concernant et
sur lequel on pourrait avoir une
communication directe avec les français
parce que le football tout le monde
m'aime moi et ce sont concernés donc
c'est vrai que le chef de l'état pour
l'instant laisse faire la ministre des
sports les sphères aussi le ministre de
l'intérieur qui a fait une espèce de
beauvau du foot après deux jours après
les incidents entre le match et lyon et
marseille et puis les sept groupes de
travail alors c'est ce que vous
expliquez tout à l'heure et fait qui
montre là la fédération entre les
ministères de l'intérieur des sports et
de la justice et on en aura les
conclusions dans une dizaine de jours
mais pour l'instant emmanuel macron je
pense à un avis très ferme sur la
question peut-être que vous le savez
peut-être vous aller mouiller je me suis
lié mais il ne se tête pour le moment
oui alors effectivement parce qu'il
s'affiche enfin de foot notamment fans
de l'om ils en sont en cache absolument
pas le prénom d'un public il peut pas
rester indifférent à cette situation
sacha houcke peut-être que c'est aussi
délégué à la ministre des sports qui a
bien pris le sujet il ya quelque chose
qui s'est passé il ya quelques jours cas
pas cas pas eu beaucoup de d'incidence
mais en tout cas quel élément essentiel
c'est la réunion de l'instance nationale
du supporterisme a été créée par une loi
en 2016 cette instance elle regroupe à
la fois donc tous les instants ce que
vous avez dit c'est à dire les la
fédération la ligue les pouvoirs publics
les ministres les références supporters
les supporters en général pour discuter
de ces questions là depuis depuis
2002 fin 2006 même jusqu'en 2016 qu'on
avait essayé de faire c'était davantage
de répression avec des textes
interdiction d'une pratique de stan
interdiction commerciale de stade bref
plein de mesures qui sont des plantes
est de plus en plus restrictive et
compass produit des effets très probant
en 2016 on a inversé la logique qui on a
mis tout le monde autour de la table ça
a permis de faire des expérimentations
sur les tribunes debout sa famille de
discuter des fumigènes ça va bien
discuter sur le transfert de
responsabilités même si c'est pas encore
organisés vers les clubs de supporters
et puis ça a permis d'avoir tous ces
discussions sur les déplacements des
polémiques déjà en 2019 autour des
déplacements des sourds ou
d'interdiction exactement et donc qu'a
mené du d'ailleurs une circulaire de
christophe castaner rappelant au préfet
que le principe c'est le déplacement et
donc c'est ce que doivent encadrer dans
la mesure du possible de les préfets et
donc cette réunion de ligonnès elle va
d'une instance nationale du
supportérisme elle a donné lieu à
plusieurs pistes et qui sont celles que
je vous décrivais plus ou moins on a les
outils juridiques judiciaires qui nous
permette de prononcer des sanctions
lorsqu'on a des comportements qui sont
des viandes et ensuite on a une question
de la préparation vous donne des
exemples ni à nice ni à lyon ni à lens
où il ya des incidents avis étaient les
incidents entre supporters lensois et
lillois qui était quasiment dans la même
cabine parce qu'il est pas de filets
comment on peut laisser faire ça alors
que ça a été identifié par la direction
nationale de lutte contre le communisme
par ailleurs ce que disait
gaitan sur la question des dénombre deux
stadiers la formation des stadiers on a
la même chose quand toutes les
professions insuffisance du nombre de
stadiers parce qu'on a repris pas assez
manque de formation parce que il faut
les mettre tout de suite sur le terrain
et ça c'est des choses qu'on a vues
recevait le rationnement valorisé alors
c'est une chose qu'on a vu et qui est
mise finalement l'organisation du match
finalement il n'ya pas aussi un peu
d'hypocrisie de la part des présidents
de clubs michel ça va parce qu'ils ont
les moyens ils ont les moyens
d'identifier les fauteurs de troubles
ils ont les moyens de mettre plus
d'argent mais on va voir des noms je
serais d'accord a d'abord je suis pas
d'accord d'abord je suis pas d'accord
sur les effets probants il ya les
sanctions qui sont qui sont
administratif ou judiciaire
mais aujourd'hui une grosse faille c'est
qu'aujourd'hui aucun contrôle qui est
fait à l'entrée des stades
aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui a interdit de
stade aujourd'hui a pas un fichier avec
la photographie il doit pointer au
commissariat oui mais ce que lorsque la
rencontre a lieu dans son dans son stade
pour son équipe mais c'est pas vrai
pendant ce temps à l'extérieur non non
il peut pas aujourd'hui ce qu'on a fait
a interrogé un certain nombre de
présidents et autres aujourd'hui il ya
besoin de pouvoir
surveiller contrôler les personnes qui
rentrent dans le stade qui sont
aujourd'hui qu'ont subi une sanction une
interdiction de cinq
ans je vais au parc des princes
vous rentrez vous oublié mais vous
rentrez pas on ne monte pas une carte
d'identité bosco rentrer dans le stade
ça dépend des clubs à paris c'est
systématique peut-être qu'apparaisse
estimates et c'est pas dans tous les
clubs et deuxièmement aujourd'hui
il ya besoin aussi d'avoir un contrôle
par rapport à gens qui ont une sanction
à éviter qu'ils reproduisent
leur présence dans les salles donc je
pense qu'aujourd'hui la sanction existe
ce qu'il voulait renforcer pas moi je
suis même pas très partisan de renforcer
les tensions qui existent il faut les
appliquer aujourd'hui elles ne sont pas
appliquées ou pas assez appliqué donc
c'est un premier volet sur lequel nous
devons travailler mais ça c'est là vous
avez raison c'est la loi à mettre en
place un dispositif de permettre le
meilleur contrôle alors si je suis tous
les des personnes qui sont condamnées
par la voie administrative ou judiciaire
sont aujourd'hui pointés un commissariat
ça m'étonnait d'abord la gendarmerie et
la police a d'autres choses à faire que
de pointer les les les personnes qui ont
des sanctions mais par contre qu'on
puisse mettre en place des contrôles
beaucoup plus efficaces qui permettent
d'éviter avec les perceptions sociales
proviennent d'un des stades ce serait
quand même un point important c'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui on va voir dans un
instant avec six jours d'un gisement de
me rejoindre ce qui les lois qu'on pût
être votées depuis depuis une trentaine
d'années il est là steve rebond somme a
effectivement ça fait 30 ans qu'on
légifère oui depuis le début des années
90 morts au total en 30 ans six grands
textes de lois ont été adoptées pour
lutter contre les débordements premier
grand texte il est adoptée en
1996 doit s'achever ollier qui n'est pas
tout à fait d'accord
le premier grand texte 1985 c'est la
convention européenne sur les violences
des spectateurs cette convention oblige
les clubs à mettre en place des
dispositifs de prévention aux violences
comme la séparation des supporters
d'équipés rivales dans les gradins
deuxième vantex achats ollier 1993 avec
la loi impulsée par michèle alliot marie
michèle alliot marie ministre de la
jeunesse et des sports du gouvernement
balladur cette loi prévoit une peine
d'interdiction de stade pour les
supporters les plus violents c'est une
mesure répressive qui est prononcée par
un tribunal cette peine ne peut excéder
cinq ans en avance un peu thomas moi
j'ai cinq ans on avance 6 et 5 ans mais
c'est la prochaine c'est 2006 à huy
après
pasqua mais moi pasqua de 1995 alterné
cette loi d'obliger les clubs assurer un
service d'ordre dans certaines
conditions mais il faut attendre 2006 à
chablis et la loi du 23 janvier pour
franchir une nouvelle étape cette loi
instaure les interdictions
administratives de stade il ne s'agit
plus d'une sanction pénale prononcée par
un tribunal c'était ce qui était prévu
par la loi de 1993 désormais le préfet
peut interdire par un simple arrêté à un
individu de se rendre dans un stade ou
aux abords d'une enceinte sportive si
cet individu institue une menace pour
l'ordre public et moi j'ai quatre textes
la voix label le prochain rift cinq ans
plus tard thomas on va encore plus loin
avec la loi du 14 mars 2011 avec cette
loi les autorités peuvent restreindre la
liberté d'aller et venir des personnes
qui se revendique de la qualité de
supporter et qui se comporte comme tel
aux abords des stades et puis dernière
mesure en date thomas la loi de 2016 sur
le hooliganisme à le prêt permet au club
de refuser la vente de billets ou
d'abonnements aux supporters violents
elle permet aussi à au club de
constituer des fichiers sains pour
recenser ces spectateurs alors faut-il
aller plus loin à ce qu'il faut adopter
un nouveau projet loi une nouvelle loi
pour l'instant du côté au goût du
gouvernement nous dit que l'urgence et
surtout d'appliquer les textes qui
existe de mieux appliquer les textes
existants merci
merci où on est d'accord on est
totalement d'accord très bien est-ce
qu'on peut s'inspirer du modèle
britannique tient véritablement alors le
modèle britannique qui effectivement a
permis en tout cas d'endiguer le
hooliganisme je crois que notre confrère
monsieur hourcade en a parlé tout à
l'heure dans les stades en angleterre où
il était très endémique
il se trouve qu'en angleterre je ne suis
pas sûr que ce soit totalement
duplicable en france mais en tout cas ce
qu'il faut ce qu'il faut se dire c'est
que l'interdiction de stade va jusqu'à
10 ans nous chez nous c'est cinq ans que
par ailleurs ils ont pris des mesures
très très forte d'un point de vue
punitif ils ont augmenté le prix des
billets
ce n'est pas notre exactement pour
finalement endiguer une partie de la
population qui était présumé violente
mais présumé pauvres voilà ensuite ils
ont et surtout en fait dans le parcage
au sein du stade ils sont à deux mètres
des joueurs donc déjà l'envahissement de
terrain s'est pas trop possible
et surtout ils sont vraiment dans des
zones très délimité ils sont pas du tout
au contact de l'équipe adverse en fait
et ce qui fait que ça permet aussi
d'éviter de se chauffer les uns les
autres et je pense que ça en revanche ça
pourrait être une piste par chez nous
mais sacha aulisi les lois existent et
que le gouvernement décrète qu'il n'en
fera pas d'autres parce que celle-ci
suffisent et que les incidents se
multiplient ça veut bien dire que les
lois ne sont pas respectées monsieur
auquel sont certifiés non mais quand on
vous écoute c'est vrai monsieur on voit
que malgré des interdictions de stade on
peut entrer dans les stades etc comment
faire pas je viens là on est face à un
dilemme très concret et quelques les
lois existent et qu'elles soient
suffisantes on a démontré avec marie
george buffet dans le rapport qu'on a
commis c'est à dire sur les
interdictions judiciaires qui sont
appliquées celles qui ont été prononcées
à l'encontre des fauteurs de trouble à
nice ou à lyon sur les interdictions
administratives qui au départ devait
permettre le temps la procédure
d'interdire aux gens d'aller au stade
avec les pointages obligatoire au
commissariat que ce soit des matchs à
domicile des matches à l'extérieur les
personnes ne pouvant pas aller se
promener partout en france pour voir son
équipe à l'extérieur lorsqu'elle est
interdite de voir son équipe les
interdictions commerciales qui sont
utilisés à paris pour 70 personnes
environ et à lens récemment après des
incidents deux ans il donc s'est
appliqué en ce conte moi aujourd'hui et
ce qui est vraiment peut être appliqué
très rapidement celles équipant des
stades donc là la responsabilité qui
pèse sur les clubs j'ai pas le défilé le
nombre d'agents qui sont présents le
respect des préconisations la direction
nationale de lutte contre le
hooliganisme en amont des matches des
matches couperets avec la même la
publication de ces préconisations des
petits plats de fête l'implication des
références supporters qui siège dans ces
réunions de préparation et qui met
chacun devant ses responsabilités
tout ça c'est des éléments qui peuvent
être mis très rapidement en place et qui
peuvent changer la donne sur
l'organisation images de contrôle c'est
ce que je comprends et je trouve je
trouve que d'aller devant sedan sur
cette voie là
cc c'est pas ma mes yeux c'est pas
répondre aux vrais problèmes parce que
ce quoi dire qu'on va arriver on va voir
arriver une désaffection du public
familial qui ne nuira plus dans un stade
parce qu'il ya des grillages de partout
parce qu'il ya des boucliers pour se
vendre et j'ai les joueurs pour les
virages a tiré un corner ça va être un
problème aussi
totalement pied voilà il ya une
population de plus en plus peut-être
moins bien
parce qu'il ya de l'ambiance c'est parce
qu'il ya des ultras qui qui met
l'ambiance c'est aussi ça le jeu le
sport et le foot
mais qu'on met de l'ambiance des
différences entre ultras et hooligans à
la lonab et qu'on met de l'ambiance
hostile à fait normal qu'ils aient des
chances d'aller dans les stades bien des
supporters mais on parle de violence et
de aujourd'hui de sécurité un simple
aujourd'hui vous avez des familles qui
ne vont plus dans un stade de foot parce
qu'aujourd'hui veut le plus emmener un
enfant de le risque de soi l'intérieur
sur l'extérieur du stade avoir des
agressions il ya une première activité
économique
aujourd'hui des clubs qui sont pénalisés
financièrement les stades à huis clos
des pénalités tout ça est économiquement
lorsqu on se connaît aujourd'hui la
situation des clubs de football
professionnels en france à part un ou
deux clubs qui encore une une base
financière solide les eaux sont tous en
grande difficulté donc c'est aussi un
problème qui va accentuer les
difficultés économiques donc tous là je
pense qu'il faut j'ai pas la gâcher pas
la certitude qu au contraire de mon
collègue que les peines soit appliquée
je pense qu'il faut qu'on travaille sur
une forte application qui a un vrai
contrôle à l'entrée des stades pour ne
plus faire rentrer les ce qui viendra
pauvre ya une semaine à l'extérieur
dessin tout à l'heure de monsieur dubé
mais aujourd'hui on organise les
rencontres de entre supporters à
l'extérieur on organise des bailleurs
sur les parkings piscine ça arrive bien
jailli à différents niveaux qui sont
données malheureusement ça fait ça fait
longtemps mais il faudrait pouvoir
l'empêcher oui je voudrais quand même
ajouté un point qu'on n'a pas soulevé
qui est quand même que aussi il ya
parfois un double discours de certains
présidents de club qui est aussi parfois
ne joue pas totalement le jeu de l'
intransigeance absolue vis des zus
league ahl exactement exactement je
pense d'ailleurs très clairement à jean
michel aulas le président du club de
l'union qui quand c'est à l'extérieur
que dimitri payet est pris est pris à
partie
contre c'était à nice en tout début de
championnat en août pas forcément c'est
la faute des autres et il faut
sanctionner le club de nice mais par
contre quand c'est chez lui la défaite
sur tapis vert défaite sur tapis vert
lancé chez lui c'est pas la faute de ses
supporters bon ben voilà il ya aussi
cette cet état de fait alors c'est qu'il
faut que les coloniaux nicolas hourcade
qui nous écoute puis tout à l'heure qui
est pas sur ce plateau c'est forcément
plus compliqué quand on n'est pas sur le
plateau voulu
intervenir sur quels points sur
plusieurs points
depuis l'été on voit un peu les pouvoirs
publics et les autorités sportives qui
se renvoient la balle la lfp a appelé
les ministères à l'aide les pouvoirs
publics ont appelé les clubs et la ligue
et à se responsabiliser
en fait les exemples étrangers que vous
avez vos clients plusieurs choses une
montre d'abord qu'il ya pas de solution
miracle s'il ya des solutions durables
pour lutter contre le hooliganisme les
connaîtrez mais il montre aussi qu'il
faut mettre en place une politique
globale et que c'est à l'état de le
faire en angleterre vous avez évoqué la
politique globale qui a été mise en
oeuvre qui revient pas mais en allemagne
à une autre politique globale qui est
mise en place au même moment dans les
années 90 qui est différente et qui est
tout aussi intéressante c'est l'idée là
aussi d'être extrêmement sévères
vis-à-vis des supporters violents mais
pas de faire un soir tout le monde n'est
pas d'augmenter le prix des places comme
en angleterre de garder de tribune
debout de garder les tarifs attractifs
mais on travaille sur la prévention
sociale sur le dialogue était supporters
et sur un train et sociales
d'accompagnement des jeunes supporters
pour qu'ils n'arrivent pas vers la
violence donc ça montre déjà qui a
différentes politiques globales possible
et que c'est à la france de construire
son propre modèle et que dans tous les
pays il faut une articulation comme
sacha où les nazis entre répression et
prévention en ce qui concerne la loi et
son application la loi actuellement elle
est suffisante il n'a pas nécessité n'a
changé elle permet de traiter le
problème en revanche elle n'a pas été
suffisamment appliqués notamment parce
qu'en france on a privilégié les
sanctions contre les clubs qu'un club
qui organisait un match sanctionné ok
mais on a privilégié les fermetures de
tribunes les huis clos alors qu'en
angleterre ou en allemagne pour lutter
contre le hooliganisme
comme je lui dis ils ont sanctionné
individuellement les fauteurs de
troubles et c'est là dessus qu'on n'a
pas été suffisamment bon et c'est aussi
depuis août qu'on n'a pas été aussi
actif qu'on aurait dû l'être sur le
dialogue avec les différents acteurs par
exemple sacha rhoul y évoquer d'un
sensationnel du supportérisme malgré les
demandes pressantes de certains nombre
puisque je suis fait partie de cette
instance elle n'a pas été réuni entre
août et décembre alors qu'on était dans
une situation extrêmement critique donc
aujourd'hui il faut des sanctions
individuelles contre les fauteurs de
troubles je vous rassure les
interdictions judiciaires et les
missions administratives sont bel et
bien contrôlée par du pointage en
revanche ce qu'on ne peut pas contrôler
c'est qu'un interdiction est mise en
place par le club parce qu'il n'a pas
les moyens de police pour le pur pour
les vérifier et je rassure les auditeurs
et les téléspectateurs
une interdiction prononcée par le club
s'est pas ravir la loi ne définit pas
clairement il mériterait d'être précisés
mais c'est maximum 18 mois
donc en résumé moi ce que j'espère c'est
qu'avec ces réunions qu'on a vu ces
dernières semaines on met enfin en place
une politique globale en articulant
différents leviers et en
responsabilisant tout le monde mais il
faut maintenant que l'impulsion vient
vraiment de l'état et qu'on applique la
loi les différentes mesures qu'on a dans
une disposition quand vous dites nicolas
hourcade qu'il faut accentuer les
sanctions individuelles cas d'école
comment on fait dans le cas de la
tribune d'auteuil qui c'est qui est la
tribune qui met l'ambiance au parc des
princes qu'il fêtait ses 30 ans c'était
le 20 novembre dernier ces belles fêtes
j'étais aux excellents des mecs super
solaire ils ont dégainé environ 550
fumigènes s'est passé avec la fille qui
avais je sais pas même avec les caméras
comment qui a trouvé ce qui tenait les
familles je vous hais ce que je vais
aussi une excellente remarque que vous
faites parce qu'on a un gros problème
aujourd'hui est que les sanctions
disciplinaires qui sont à peu près les
mêmes pour l'allumage de fumigènes
festif que pour les jets de fumigènes
sur le terrain ou coup pour des
violences graves comme celles qu'on a vu
depuis août est donc l'une des
difficultés qui a été pointée par
plusieurs acteurs du football c'est que
les sanctions de la commission de
discipline de la ligue elles sont pas
visibles elles sont pas proportionnés on
comprend pas véritablement comment elles
sont appliquées donc il est nécessaire
de les repenser et de responsabiliser
les clubs mais avec des sanctions
claires et sur les fumigènes sa survie
il me semble à rappeler on est en train
de mettre en place actuellement une
expérimentation pour un allumage
contrôle et des fumigènes s'ils ont
résolu ce problème en permettant aux
supporters d'allumer des fumigènes dans
un cadre bien sécurisé on résoudrait
énormément de problèmes puisque la
plupart des sanctions contre les clubs
sont prononcés pour les à l'image de
fumigènes il faut une qu'on se concentre
sur la violence sur les insultes qu'on a
dans les stades parfois caractère
raciste on alterne plusieurs saluts
nazis depuis le début de la saison je
pense qu il faut s en préoccuper ça me
paraît plus grave que l'anniversaire
somptueux de la tribune auteuil qui a
été saluée par tous les médias et qui a
donné lieu à des merveilleuses images
alors effectivement ça fait de la fumée
mais c'est quand même beaucoup moins
grave qu'un jet de projectile sur
dimitri payet ou qu un envahissement de
terrain ou des saluts nazis
effectivement je suis assez d'accord
avec avec vous nicolas hourcade
sacha oublier ça veut dire quoi il faut
revoir effectivement les l'échelle des
sanctions en fonction des actes non
c'est d'abord ça veut dire que les
sanctions elles devaient d'abord être
appliquée pour les faits qui sont les
plus graves dans les stades c'est à dire
les violences les comportements
inappropriés le racisme l'antisémitisme
mais craquait à un fumigène on y vient
juste une précision sur les
interdictions commercial qu'on a décrit
tout à l'heure c'est aujourd'hui maximum
100 personnes en france contrôlé par le
club et les clubs comme le paris saint
germain par exemple ont fait l'objet
d'une déclaration auprès de la cnil pour
pouvoir afficher pouvoir contrôler les
personnes raison pour laquelle il ya ce
contrôle d'identité au parc des princes
i à 15 personnes en france 77e pro parc
des princes et une trentaine à lancer
sur les interactions commerciales 200
aujourd'hui semble pas beaucoup non
c'est pas pour me dire ce léger recul
est pas parce que les clubs aujourd'hui
sont il faut crise la visière supporters
j'y reviens
sur les fumigènes sur les fumigènes sur
les films viennent il ya une comme une
grande hypocrisie d'abord pourquoi cet
interdit les fumigènes au départ parce
qu'on cherche à protéger des brûlures
quand on demande à tous les clubs tous
les clubs depuis dix ans combien de
supporters ou combien de type de
brûlures il ya dans les stades même
cadre il ya eu dans les stades c'est
zéro et on a fait cette démarche là avec
quasiment tous les clubs de ligue 1 donc
il y en a là il y en a eu pour les 30
ans de la tribune auteuil débrouille est
ce qu'il ne fallait pas déguiser mais
déclarations sociales pardon mais où est
donc sûre c'est qu'ils savent feu les
pompiers sont intervenus
il rêvait quand même un peu trop des
films durs c'était beau mais un peu trop
de ça aussi c'est parce qu'on a
systématisé les sanctions c'est la même
sanction s'il ya une chimie gêne au
cinéma 500 bon ça c'est un problème
aussi dit est-ce que sur ce sujet là on
a effectivement un sujet de
l'égalisation d'encadrement et paris re
de transfert de la responsabilité parce
que le problème aujourd'hui c'est le
club organise qui est responsable de des
fumigènes qui sont traqués par ses
supporters août une espèce de dialogue
un peu hypocrite au sida qui s'installe
alors que si on organisait le transfert
des responsabilités vers l'association
de supporters qui craquent avec les
responsabilités civiles et pénales qui
sont liées et qui serait sur le
président de l'association de supporters
là on aurait peut-être beaucoup plus
d'autorégulation et beaucoup plus de
contrôle la question du début de ce
débat que fait manuel mata mais ça pour
le coup c'est quelque chose qu'on a
écrit dans le rapport avec marie george
buffet qu'on a proposé et kate ont
déballé donc on balaye sport pour que ce
soit la fusion une nouvelle injustice
tout à l'heure on a parlé ou à comparer
la france avec l'angleterre et
l'allemagne il ya 500 interdictions de
stades en france et on assimile en
allemane inadi milan manque de terres
voilà donc une quand je dis et quand on
est plusieurs à dire que les sanctions
sont pas appliquées au niveau lorsque
des sanctions administratives ou des
clubs par rapport à l'interdiction de
rentrer 70 personnes
c'est ridicule commerciales
ont été produites soit dans un stade et
le club sanctionna personnes qui
quittent pas passer au tribunal ni
passer à la sanction administrative mais
cas si elle était sanctionné c'est
qu'elle a fait des actes sont
répréhensibles
dans un stade et on doit contrôler et 70
personnes merci beaucoup merci à tous
merci nicolas hourcade merci à toutes
les tous les quatre